ويمكننا أن نذهب الآن إلى إيزاروف وهو
مراسل لصحيفة الحارة
ويغطي الشؤون الفلسطينية أم أه
أحداث غير مسبوقة نراها تتكشف
الآن خلال الساعتين الأخيرتين ما
يمكن أن يكون الهدف من هذه
العملية ولسنوات كنت
تغطية قيادة حماس ولا أستطيع
إلا أن أفترض أن الهدف من هذه الحرب
ربما أسميها عملية لكنها
لم تعد عملية إنها
إعلان حرب كان الهدف هو أخذ
بعض الرهائن لاختطاف مواطنين
وجنود إسرائيليين من أجل  القيام بنوع من
الاتفاق مع إسرائيل في المستقبل
لإطلاق سراح مئات إن لم يكن الآلاف من
السجناء الفلسطينيين من
السجون الإسرائيلية، وهذا عادة ما تفكر فيه حماس
في هذا النوع من العمليات، ونحن
نرى أننا نعرف بالفعل أنهم تمكنوا
من اختطاف بعض الأشخاص.  الإسرائيليون
لست متأكدًا مما إذا كانوا جنودًا أم
مدنيين في ضواحي قطاع غزة
داخل البلدات والقرى الإسرائيلية،
لكنهم تمكنوا من القيام بذلك، وشاهدنا
صورًا مروعة للمجازر التي
وقعت في تلك البلدات والقرى التي
نعيشها.  الحديث عن عشرات الضحايا
من الجانب الإسرائيلي في هجوم مفاجئ
لا يوجد تعريف آخر له سوى
وصفه بأنه إعلان حرب ويؤسفني
حقًا أن أقول ذلك ولكن في
الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة ربما نرى نتيجة
هذا  وهذا يعني الانتقام من
الجانب الإسرائيلي، وسيكون هناك العديد من
الضحايا في الجانب الفلسطيني في
غزة، ولا أستطيع إلا أن أقول كم أنا آسف لما
قررت قيادة حماس
القيام به نيابة عن جميع سكان قطاع
غزة.